[Музика]
привіт, привіт, дорогі учні, ласкаво просимо назад
на наші уроки. Уроки англійської мови та мистецтва
сьогодні наш останній урок, ми
поглянемо на всі слова для камери, бабуся,
усе, що ми вже вивчили,
і сьогодні у нас є особливий гість,
мій BFF  Андреа привіт, Ольга, як справи, я
добре, дякую, що прийшли на урок
сьогодні, ваша проблема правильно добре
, ви дивилися мої попередні уроки, я
маю, вони дійсно цікаві, добре
дізналися, багато чого
добре, дякую, дуже добре, ми багато розглянули
мистецтво ми говорили про картини ми
говорили про види мистецтва ми говорили про
періоди та історію, але ми не
торкнулися дуже цікавої теми, що
мистецтво, яке є найбільш привабливим для більшості
підлітків, на мій погляд, ви маєте на увазі музику,
ми не говоримо про  виконавське
мистецтво ммм, можливо, література,
на жаль, сьогодні підлітки не дуже багато читають,
що це може бути
добре, дозвольте мені сказати вам ключові слова, і
ви зможете вгадати правильне соціальне повідомлення, ага,
незаконно.
я так
графіті так мій улюблений
подивіться на це
круто ви знаєте, хто це зробив ммм я думаю,
можливо, Бенксі так
, до речі, ви маєте рацію, що я можу сказати про те, що Роб
я використовую щодо графіті, чи
ви створюєте його  ти малюєш це, я знепритомнів,
як розпилення фарби,
так, дуже добре, так, ти
щось знаєш про Бенксі, я знаю, що він
трохи суперечливий і що його
повідомлення, як правило, досить політичні, і
вони мають як соціальну підводну течію,
я думаю, що він дуже цікавий
художник графіті, тому що у нього є повідомлення,
і це не просто вандалізм на стінах,
це щось говорить людям, так,
він справді, і найпривабливішим знову
для підлітків є той факт, що він
невідомий, так, він прихований, його ніхто ніколи не
бачив, так,
дозвольте мені прочитати  ти найбільша новина у
світі мистецтва у 2018 році. Я бачив це на BBC, і я
думаю, що це дуже цікаво,
коли хтось багатий витрачає 1 мільйон
фунтів стерлінгів на картину, від якої вони не
очікують неприємних сюрпризів, але цей 2006 sp  променевий
малюнок відомого художника графіті
Бенксі був подрібнений, як тільки
його продали, відбиток був у великій
рамці, всередині якої був захований подрібнювач,
і раптом полотно
раптом почало проходити крізь нього,
картина була відбитком  одна з банків у
найвідоміших роботах дівчина з повітряною кулею, ну,
ось ця, яку ви щойно показали мені, так,
як жахливо, так, але у нас є
гарне відео про це, ви хотіли
б його побачити, давайте подивимося правильно, подія
відбулася в  аукціон, а ти
знаєш, що таке аукціон,
де купують і продають картини, так, чи
є дилери, у нас є
аукціон, а люди закривають
ціни так, ти коли-небудь був на
аукціоні, на якому я був  аукціон, але ми
любимо проводити тихі аукціони, це
справді крута річ, коли ви розміщуєте
багато творів мистецтва, є реєстраційний
лист, ви просто ходите навколо і
пишете своє ім’я та скільки ви хочете
витратити на щось це  великий
збір коштів, щоб зробити f  або різні події.
випадкове
питання, чи ми робимо ставки та продаємо його
за сто шістдесят
[Оплески]
[Музика]
що ви думаєте про це добре, я думаю, що
спочатку аукціон здається дуже хаотичним,
усі називають цифри та
намагаються поставити ставку на твір мистецтва  але
кінець, щоб витратити всі ці гроші
і подрібнити їх на твоєму обличчі, так
, це дуже шокує, і весь
світ сказав так, цікаво, що було за
меседж, що він намагався виправитися,
коли я побачив новини, я вірю в
повідомлення  що Бенксі дав усім
, світу мистецтва та користувачам
мистецтва, це те, що навіть знищення мистецтва може бути
величезним актом мистецтва, тому в нашій карті розуму
ми можемо включити нас як мистецтво перформансу так,
перформанс, круто, так  але я думаю, що я
хотів би піти на аукціон і
спробувати поставити ставку на якийсь вид мистецтва, це
виглядає дуже
весело  Було б
добре, щоб запитання було на
початку відео, щоб я
міг його прослухати, тому що це
дійсно хороша техніка, так, у мене вона є
на початку, тому ми переглянемо його ще раз
і дізнаємося, так, дозвольте мені розповісти
студенти щоразу, коли ви збираєтеся
виконувати вправу, і вам надається
запитання, будь ласка,
зверніть увагу на запитання, прочитайте його
уважно, тому, коли ви слухаєте, у цьому
випадку, коли ви дивитеся відео, ви
будете шукати точну відповідь давайте
переглянемо відео  знову, і
питання в тому, скільки грошей
продали остаточні картини за так добре, давайте
подивимося відео знову
[Музика]
[Оплески]
800 000 тиск останній шанс на
вісімсот п'ятдесят тисяч вісім
шістдесят вісімсот шістдесят тисяч справедливий
warni  Чи можу я продати його зараз за
вісімсот шістдесят тисяч, питання останнього шансу,
чи ми зараз робимо ставки та продаємо 360
[Оплески]
[Музика
] Гаразд, Андреа, а чи знаєте ви зараз,
скільки коштувала сіль для фарбування нарешті,
так, вісімсот шістдесят тисяч
фунти, і миттєво це, Боже,
це, можливо, дуже велика трата грошей, але
я думаю, це був дуже крутий спосіб показати
повідомлення Бенксі, так, це відео
дуже складне, тому що вони завжди змінюють
свої номери, так, вони повертаються
і  туди-сюди так, але
вісімсот шістдесят тисяч фунтів стерлінгів,
це дуже багато грошей, так,
майже два мільйони, майже мільйон, так.
графіті -
це досить суперечлива тема
графіті я не дуже фанат я справді
так я думаю, що це руйнує архітектуру
я не знаю архітектура - це вид
мистецтва, і тут хтось доклав увесь цей
час і зусилля  jw.org uk хтось просто
бере балончик і малює його по всьому,
не поважаючи простір іншої людини,
тож якщо я задам вам питання чи
номер 50, добре, чи
що ви скажете, я, ймовірно,
стверджу, що акт вандалізму правильний, чому б і ні
ми показуємо дуже цікаву техніку
дебатів для наших студентів, які впевнені, що дебатують,
і саме тоді, коли дві суперечливі ідеї
зустрічаються, і вам потрібно мати достатньо сильних
і підтримуючих повідомлень, щоб продовжувати йти, щоб
виграти дебати правильно, а також
це може бути дуже корисно для  написання есе,
коли у вас є абзаци
з новими ідеями, щоб зробити його сильним і
потужним, щоб ключове повідомлення в кожному
з абзаців ви
пишете правильно  Я не був шанувальником графіті, просто
живучи в Україні, ми не бачимо
красивих і потужних графіті, поки вони не
з'явилися нещодавно, у нас було кілька
муралів, створених цим різним
видом мистецтва, але я був у  У Торонто три
роки тому там є
прекрасна алея з графіті,
о так, ось тут я закохався
в цей тип,
і саме тут я зрозумів,
чому це подобається підліткам, але давайте перейдемо
до дискусії мм-хм,
дозвольте мені порахувати  Я вважаю, що у мене є п'ять
пунктів, а що щодо вас, я можу пригадати
п'ять пунктів, чому я вважаю, що графіті - це
вандалізм,
я можу пригадати п'ять пунктів, чому я вважаю, що з
графіті все гаразд, добре,
ви починаєте писати графіті завжди має
соціальне повідомлення, яке легко бути  призначено
спеціально для підлітків і
різного віку, так, але якщо ви подивитеся на соціальне
повідомлення, це може бути образливим для деяких
людей, і, гуляючи вулицею, вони
можуть образитися на графіті
на стіні, це може говорити щось проти
їхньої системи переконань і  Я не думаю, що
це справді справедливо, що просто
ходити вулицею хтось може завдати вам шкоди.
ах, ви
маєте право.
Це видно всім людям не
потрібно платити людям не потрібно ходити
в галереї, це просто там, так
, це правда,
так що це доступно кожному, так, але
це також руйнує багато речей,
які вже стоять і вже є
був побудований, і я не знаю, це все одно
що захопити чужий простір, тому цей
архітектор або цей будівельник побудував цю
стіну, і це їхнє вираження мистецтва,
і хтось інший прийшов і просто
намалював все це о так, знову
третій пункт я  Я хотів би сказати, що зазвичай
графіті-художники досить молоді, і
спрей досить доступний, вони можуть
легко його купити і висловити, тому
для мене це доступність, о
круто, я ніколи не думав про це з цієї
точки зору,
я бачу лише кримінальний аспект
вандалізму  навіть Бенксі ніхто не знає, хто
він, його ніхто не бачив, його мистецтво
з'являється посеред ночі, тому я
думаю, що це трохи небезпечно і,
можливо, навіть незаконно, тому що вони повинні
йти в райони, де  люди зазвичай не
ходять і не роблять це вночі,
коли темно, це може бути небезпечно.
трохи художнього смаку або
іноді вони сповнені ви знаєте
мистецькі ідеї, і вони мають шанс
нарешті висловити себе так, це
правда, але хоча іноді вони
для молодих людей робляться молодими
людьми, може виникнути ідея
позначити мікрорайон  і сказати, що це моя
територія, і тому це може майже
заохочувати таку поведінку
позначення територій і створення
районів, куди люди не хочуть йти,
тому це також може бути трохи небезпечним,
коли ви говорите про групи, на яких
я думав  з фактично підлітків ви знаєте,
як групи підлітків, які надають
графіті, називаються своїми бригадами, тож це
ще один соціальний аспект об’єднання
людей навколо їх інтересів, їх
хобі, а саме арт-графіті O  h чудово,
я ніколи не вважав це
майже тимбілдингом або створенням спільноти, я
завжди вважав це ізоляцією людей
від спільноти ах
добре, о, о, я не відчуваю, що хтось із
нас є тут, так, що ми поділилися
ідеями так  приємно було
побачити обидві сторони, тому що
особливо коли ви пишете есе, ви
повинні подивитися на обидві сторони
аргументації, щоб показати, що ви провели певне
дослідження, так, це може бути
дискусія, коли ви щось обговорюєте
і ви '  не намагаючись перемогти свого
опонента, ви намагаєтеся просто поділитися
ідеєю, що у вас все добре
, а також для есе ви можете запропонувати, щоб
абзац перший був за так, а потім
другий або третій абзац проти, і тоді
все закінчилося  ви вирішите, якою є ваша
точка зору, хм, правильно, коли ми
дивилися відео, коли ми обговорювали це, ми використовували
багато гарної граматики, яка була пасивною. О,
боже, я боюся граматики, я навчу
вас, що добре, правильно  подивитись на
речення чи правильно
Бенксі встановив подрібнювач ммм-хм,
коли ви слухаєте це речення, хто
для вас тут головна тема. Дякую,
він правильний, але якщо я скажу, що
подрібнювач був встановлений Бенксі, тоді
ми перемикаємо його на подрібнювач,
коли  ми хочемо добре сказати об'єкт, з яким
щось трапилося, ми просто
створюємо пасивний залог, і це досить легко,
структура проста так, у нас є
підмет, тоді у нас є дієслово to be
у правильній формі, але або MBA є was
was або will be  так, давайте спробуємо ще якийсь
хороший подрібнювач знищив картину,
тому подрібнювач є основною частиною
речення так, а тепер переключіть
його на малюнок ммм,
допоможіть мені, картина була подрібнена
так або знищена або знищена так,
подрібнювач знищив картину зараз
ви поміняєте тему та об'єкт
добре картина була знищена так, а як
щодо цієї
наші дилери ми говоримо про аукціони
тут купуйте картини на аукціонах, зараз
ми говоримо про мистецтво  торговці як
основна частина так, тож картини
зазвичай сортують
так або купують ага о так аукціон так
на аукціоні я вірю в клас,
який буде ідеальною активністю для проведення
аукціону мм-хмм
опис малюнків і перегляд
цифр чудово так, скільки вийшло  Ви
платите за найдорожчу картину, яку
маєте у вашій квартирі, о боже, я не
знаю, я не знавець мистецтва,
але у мене немає бюджету, все добре,
добре,
тому, коли ми говоримо про це, не
так  Не чудово мати алеї з графіті
та все інше, так, я був у
Бельгії влітку, і у мене також
є фестиваль мистецтва графіті, це було
дуже круто, але як можна зробити,
щоб художники виклали це на стіну, щоб
вони  нанесіть це на полотно, їм
дається ділянка вулиці, і вони створюють
там свою арку, вони розпилюють її на
стіни і щороку перефарбовують її
, зверху фарбують білим і починають
знову правильно, що
цікаво протягом попередніх
п'яти  ле  ssons ми використовуємо Lords
of present perfect і так у мене був
учень, який ми виявили, що ми використовуємо
багато present perfect навіть в
українській мові я
читав книгу протеоміка ніджо-джо ха так
кинь нижче марсіанин наш  Dania
yeah
capella Anacapa voila правильно, давайте
подивимося на загальну редакцію того, коли ми
використовуємо Present Perfect Right, тому є
п'ять основних випадків, які я люблю використовувати пальці, щоб
правильно запам'ятати речі, тому п'ять випадків,
коли ми використовуємо Present Perfect, і
перший є  про життєвий досвід
ммм-хм про речі, які ви
вже зробили, чи можете ви навести приклад того,
що ви вже зробили я
їздив Україною ви
їздили в Україну, тому повідомлення тут про
те, що ви зосереджені на  результат
ти мандрував Україною ти
зараз тут так життєвий досвід гарний а
як довго я можу задати тобі питання
в даний момент ідеально йти на це скільки
ти живеш в Україні я живу
в Україні майже сім років
так, перше – це життєвий досвід,
друге – за те, як довго ви робили
деяку подяку, правильний результат, коли ми
зосереджуємось на результаті, як я
намалював так добре, добре, студентам може здатися,
що нам бентежить будинок, але
це легко, ви завжди повинні
дотримуватися, тому ми боремося, щоб змінити речення, щоб сказати, що
мій учень добре намалював цю картину,
щоб життя відчувало, як довго
і результат останні дії, о, це
моя улюблена нещодавня дія, добре те,
що ти зробив нещодавно я  я нещодавно
купив цуценя добре, чи можу я поставити
вам справжнє запитання про те,
де ви купили свого цуценя, я
купив цуценя, якщо він хороший, ви купили в
Інтернеті, звичайно, я зробив це єдиний спосіб
робити покупки зараз, так добре, і  незавершені
дії правильно щодо чогось, чого
ми не зробили, не бачили
або не почали, можливо, не почали
так, тому я нещодавно не почав читати нову
книгу, як ця, так, у
мене не було своєї  кава ще О  кава
важлива
так, добре, добре, тому дізнайтеся здивуйте
п'ять життєвих досвідів про те, як довго у вас
були деякі думають результат так
останні дії і незавершені дії
круто добре, а основні ключові слова, які ми маємо
, легко запам'ятати
зовсім недавно ніколи ніколи вже
інші ключові повідомлення  Я навчав своїх
студентів пам’ятати головну плутанину
між минулим простим і сучасним досконалим,
ми зазвичай маємо це в тестах, якщо ви
бачите ключові слова, то є складна річ,
пам’ятайте, що це Present Perfect,
наприклад, якщо у нас є набір слів, як я
читав учора  чи буде вона
ідеальною, чи буде вона простою, хм, я
читав учора, так, і тому,
тому що у нас є точна згадка про те,
коли це сталося, добре, але якщо ви скажете, що я
вже прочитав цю книгу, ви
перемикаєтеся від часу до
результату  я прочитав це круто добре, тепер
зрозуміло, чи не так, добре, завжди будьте
обережні, виконуючи тест і
виконуючи це, і я закликаю
всіх використовувати поточний pe  rfect у ваших есе у
ваших записах у вашій розмові, тому
що ми робимо те ж саме українською
не бійтеся використовувати present perfect
right і чи готові ви до тесту О
ні так, будь ласка, у вас є набір слів,
правда це  завжди в досконалому теперішньому часі,
ви просто повинні зробити це правильно.
Давайте разом подивимося на перше, що
ви їсте тайську їжу перед тим, як
ви їли
тайську їжу перед тим, як дякую,
звідки походить з'їдений це дієслово
так,
третя форма  це так, що Present
Perfect завжди має, а третя його
форма добре, так, давайте перейдемо до
наступної.
дуже добре, тож тут
поясніть правильне дієслово, все, що ви робите, це просто
додайте закінчення IDI have я пояснив це дуже
добре я знаю його три місяці, гм,
я знаю його три місяці так,
ми гарні, чи
можемо ми все ще сказати, що я знав його  три
місяці звучить
некоректно  так добре, так що пам'ятайте, що я
знаю когось англійською. Я завжди навчаю
своїх студентів. Я вивчав англійську
стільки років, про які ви
говорите, результат круто
наступний він пошкодив ногу, він пошкодив ногу,
так,  результат знову правильно так, він
бере таксі, це питання, чи він взяв
таксі, чи він взяв таксі, він
взяв таксі так дуже добре,
і вона залишила свій телефон у таксі о
, це жахливий момент я знаю, я знаю,
що вона поїхала  її телефон у таксі
так, який невдалий момент, я знаю, що
вона знову засміялася неправильне дієслово
входить у форму пошуку подія так,
давайте перевіримо, чи ви були праві, давайте
подивимося правильні відповіді дуже добре, чи можете ви
прочитати їх ще раз, будь ласка, переконайтеся,
що ви їли тайську  їжа раніше я
добре пояснював я знаю його
три місяці він пошкодив ногу він
взяв таксі і, нарешті, вона залишила
свій телефон у таксі, молодець я знаю, що ти
будеш використовувати більше подарунків ідеально зараз
я спробую  правильно ви згадали, що ви фін  d
теперішній план для досить складного танцю,
ми ніколи не вивчали граматику в школі, тому
я трохи приголомшений нею іноді
правильно, щоб подолати будь-які труднощі, нам
потрібно попрактикуватися в цьому добре завдання, яке я б
дав своїм учням О, перш за все, зробіть
багато  Граматичні вправи, тому що чим
більше ваша практика досконалої теперішнього часу,
тим правильнішою вона стає, але
завданням для вас буде створити
історію, в якій вам дозволено використовувати лише
досконалий теперішній час у ваших часах, тому це
має бути ваш минулий досвід, який вам
доведеться  згадати багато результатів просто
ніколи вже нещодавно добре добре,
давайте спробуємо так добре, ви коли-небудь
були на графіті, що це було б на
виставці, звичайно, так, я насправді
був кілька років тому з моєю мамою ми пішли
так, дякую, що ви згадали  Кілька років
тому,
коли ми пішли на виставку Бенксі в
Торонто, Рон ми бачили, як багато його
творів мистецтва, які були перевезені
з різних куточків світу,
передруковані та поміщені в  його виставку ми
багато читали про нього, тому що вони
використовували графіті та писали його історії
на стіні, коли я слухаю, і ось ми тут
і подобається моєму shitali мм-хм так, ми
читали так, і ми нічого не купували,
щоб презентувати ідеальний  ми не
купили нічого хорошого, так як це
було трохи дорого, але це був
чудовий досвід, і я дізнався багато
про те, як навчитися отримувати прибуток,
я так багато дізнався про Бенксі
та світ мистецтва графіті, який зробив
мене  трохи менше скептично ставився до того,
що це вандалізм.
багато хто має
та має, як правило, коли ви говорите, він
не говорить повну форму події,
ви скорочуєте її, як я дізнався, що
я купив, але якщо це
офіційний текст, як-от есе, офіційне есе
або звіт  не забудьте уникати
скорочень і вставляйте повні форми, а
якщо це просто розмова, ви,
ймовірно, звучатимете більш природно, якщо ви
добре налаштуєте короткі налаштування, чи можете ви зробити ще
кілька речень з короткими посиланнями
на виставку Бенксі.
я не купив
нічого не купив нічого не купив ми читали так
ми багато читали про нього і я бачив
так, виставку про Бенксі так
дякую дуже дякую дякую
гарна і знову ще одна
методика навчання для всіх студентів, щоб мати
можливість брати участь у дебатах
або мати можливість написати гарне есе з
сильними ключовими моментами, ви можете
або створити карту розуму, не так, як ми
робили в попередньому  урок — це весь
словниковий запас, щоб переконатися, що ви включили його
у свою письмову чи розмовну діяльність.
Інша техніка — це створення списку
, скажімо, переваг і недоліків,
так, як ми зробили це сьогодні, у вас
були п’ять ідей, або ви знову мали їх
проти мене  це  адже зазвичай, якщо я
маю час зробити це заздалегідь, вам
знадобиться всього три-чотири хвилини, щоб
створити список переваг і
недоліків, це може бути тема мистецтва
, може бути тема життя в
міському районі або так,  у сільській місцевості це
може бути що завгодно, тому, будь ласка, використовуйте цю
техніку, використовуйте свій час, щоб зробити це, і
коли це написання
інформації, завжди залишайте собі час,
щоб прочитати її ще раз, щоб ще раз перевірити мм-хм
гарна відповідь, дуже дякую, що
прийшли на сьогоднішню  урок дякую Ольга
так добре, що ви сьогодні так багато дізналися так,
продовжуйте приходити на наші уроки шановні учні
дуже дякую, ви можете почати з
перегляду уроків з 1 по 6, тому
що тут шість уроків і мистецтво з
лінійкою словниковий запас, корисна граматика і
просто красиві твори  мистецтва
шедеври дякую дуже дякую
[Музика]
вам